Західна частина Києва, пів години на метро від Майдану Незалежності -
тренувальна база полку "Азов", підрозділу в складі національної гвардії України,
за яким тягнеться недобра слава симпатій до неонацистських організацій.
Зв'язки "Азова" та інших ультраправих українських організацій в Німеччині стали предметом парламентського запиту в німецький уряд,
ініційованого фракцією Лівої партії, яка має давні зв'язки з Москвою і традиційно популярна на сході Німеччини.
Подібні запити - інструмент парламентського контролю за роботою уряду.
Згідно з рішенням Конституційного суду Німеччини, уряд зобов'язаний відповідати депутатам, причому детально і протягом двох тижнів.
Приміром, у відповіді зазначено, що в саксонському місті Пірна зареєстровано проєкт,
мета якого - організація відпусток у Німеччині для родичів бійців "Азова".
Координаторка запиту Мартіна Реннер відповіддю уряду незадоволена.
Ми саме відправили на цю тему парламентський запит в уряд і результат страхітливий!
Страхітливий, бо уряд майже нічого не знає!
Я не можу оцінити, чи отримує уряд від спецслужб інформацію, яку не передає нам в парламент -
якщо це так, то це проблематично, тому що мова йде про речі, що становлять інтерес для громадськості.
Мова про загрози, які виникають з цих контактів. І про які треба говорити відкрито.
Депутатка стверджує, що неонацисти з Німеччини їздять в Україну,
щоб потренуватися в поводженні з вогнепальною зброєю, і що спецслужби Німеччини та країн ЄС
приділяють міжнародним зв'язкам крайніх правих занадто мало уваги.
Коло неонацистів дуже вузьке. Всі вони пов'язані між собою, в тому числі і через інтернет,
набагато швидше і набагато конкретніше ніж, скажімо, років десять тому.
Наскільки працює взаємодія спецслужб - обмін інформацією, юридична допомога в рамках розслідування конкретних кримінальних справ, -
я не можу судити про це. Однак в тому, що стосується України, я можу стверджувати напевно,
що кількість названих у доповіді уряду неонацистів, про яких відомо, що вони їздили туди,
настільки мала, що це не може бути правдою.
Мартіна Реннер стверджує, що німецьких правих приваблює можливість робити за кордоном те, що заборонено в Німеччині -
від навчання, як поводитися з вогнепальною зброєю, до участі у бойових діях.
Сьогодні це Україна, через три роки може бути якась інша країна, каже депутатка.
А уряд пише, що...
Натомість Ліва партія критикує німецькі спецслужби за недостатньо цифровий
і недостатньо міжнародний підхід до боротьби з правим екстремізмом.
Однак німецькі ультраправі - у двозначній ситуації, вказують спостерігачі у Києві.
Річ у тому, що їхні загравання з українськими націоналістами швидше навіть суперечать загальній лінії
праворадикальних та правопопулістських організацій Німеччини на схвалення політики Кремля щодо України.
Так, ключові політики правоекстремістської Націонал-демократичної партії ФРН
критикують санкції проти Росії, Євромайдан називають "путчем",
а також виступали проти визнання підконтрольних Кремлю псевдореспублік "ДНР" та "ЛНР" терористичними організаціями.